Salut Romain.
Wouha ! Ca sent fort, qu'est ce que tu manges, du gibier non ?
- Non je mange pas.
- Attends, c'est toi qui sens comme ça ?
- Je comprends pas, j'ai prit ma douche la semaine dernière
En matière d'hygiène et de propreté, y'a deux types de personnes.
Celles qui se passent le visage à l'eau de Javel quand vous leur avez fait la bises.
Et celles qui lèches la barre du métro en disant :
" Roh mais ça va avant on s'en foutait des microbes et ça se passait très bien "!
Alors ceux là, on peut leur rappeler qu'au Moyen Âge l’espérance de vie c'était une petite trentaine d'année.
On peut aussi leur reparler d'une ou deux épidémies : le choléra, la peste.
Mais aux premiers, on leur dit quoi pour les calmer ?
Et bien leur dit que oui, les germes qui nous entoure ils peuvent être dangereux
Mais qu'ils ne le sont pas tous.
Et que l'hygiène c'est important mais que "le mieux ça peut aussi être l'ennemi du bien".
Un peu partout, sur et à l’intérieur de notre corps y'a des germes qui forment la "flore commensale"
Ces bactéries et ces micro-organismes jouent des rôles importants dans la digestion par exemple
Mais ils forment aussi le premier rempart contre les microbes en protégeant notre peau
Contre d'autres germes qui peuvent nous rendre malade : "les germes pathogènes".
Donc là on parle de gentils germes
Mais ils peuvent quand même vous rendre malade s'ils décident brusquement de déménager.
Si un germe qui vit dans vos intestins élit domicile dans votre vessie ou vos poumons par exemple.
Et en temps normal ces bactéries sont absolument indispensables à votre bonne santé.
Mais se laver plusieurs fois par jour ou utiliser des produits trop agressifs pour se laver
Ça peut avoir deux conséquences qui font vraiment plus de mal que de bien.
1) Tuer les gentilles bactéries qui empêchent les méchantes de rentrer.
2) Détruire la fine pellicule qui se trouve à la surface de notre peau qui s'appelle le film hydrolipidique
Qui a pour rôle de l'hydrater et de la protéger.
Dans l'absolu ce serait même pas nécessaire de prendre une douche tous les jours.
Bon par contre, faudrait quand même penser à laver les endroits les plus peuplés en bactéries.
Un moyen mnémotechnique : c'est ceux qui sentent mauvais.
Et oui parce que s'ils sentent mauvais
C'est justement à cause des bactéries qui pour le coup s'y développent en trop grand nombre.
C'est comme les soirées entre potes : même s'ils sont très gentils à un moment donné faut qu'ils s'en aillent.
Pour se développer les bactéries apprécient particulièrement la chaleur et l'humidité
Comme celles qu'on trouve dans des petits recoins comme les plis ou les zones moites et riches en poils.
J'crois qu'on se comprends.
Elles se nourrissent de peaux mortes et de molécules contenues dans la sueur par exemple
Et ce qui sent fort, c'est les gaz qu'elles rejettent en digérant tout ça.
On est bien la quand même.
- *Pet*
- Oh non t'es relou putain tu vas encore nous faire repérer.
Voilà donc sachez que de temps en temps vous pouvez vous contenter d'une "toilette de chat".
* bruit d'une personne qui tombe*
Ça va Romain ? qu'est-ce qui t’arrive ?
- J'ai essayé de faire une toilette de chat et j'ai perdu l'équilibre.
Bon alors soyons clair, faire une "toilette de chat", ça veut pas dire se laver en se léchant les parties intimes
Ca veut juste dire passer un petit coup de gant de toilettes sur les zones les plus sales.
On est d'accord ?
- Okay !
Donc vous pouvez faire l'impasse sur la douche de temps en temps.
Mais pas sur : les aisselles; les organes génitaux; le sillon interfessier (aussi appelé "la raie du cul")
Les pieds; les oreilles; les dents et les mains.
Ah et changez de gant de toilette à chaque fois parce qu'en terme de moiteur et d'humidité
C'est la fête du slip pour les bactéries là-dedans.
Bon on résume. Y'a d'un côté les gentilles bactéries qu'il ne faut pas tuer
Et de l'autre, les bactéries méchantes et celles là...
Bah faut pas les tuer non plus.
Et non pas toutes en tout cas
Même si c'est écœurant d'imaginer le nombre de bactéries qui prolifèrent sur nos claviers,
Nos écrans de smartphone, nos sacs à mains.
Oui j'ai un sac à main.
Vivre dans un milieu aseptisé c'est le meilleur moyen de se rendre vulnérable aux infections.
Parce que pour lutter contre les microbes, notre système immunitaire
Il a besoin d'y être confronté de temps en temps. Comme ça il peut fourbir ses armes : les anti-corps.
Donc nettoyer chez soi ça doit consister à faire baisser le nombre de germes à un niveau acceptable
Et pas les faire disparaitre complètement.
Laver à l'eau avec un produit d'entretien classique ça suffit.
Même  pour ce que vous portez à votre bouche, comme la vaisselle.
Ou toute autre chose que vous mettez à votre bouche.
En fait il faut réserver les désinfectants pour les endroits peuplés de bactéries vraiment méchantes.
C'est-à-dire principalement peuplés de bactéries fécales.
C'est-à-dire principalement vos toilettes.
Ou tout autre endroit où vous stockez votre caca.
Alors généralement, à ce stade, viennent les question sur la nourriture.
Donc je vous propose de faire un petit point culinaire.
Bon, on est d'accord, on lave ses aliments ni à l'eau de Javel ni même au savon.
D'ailleurs le plus sale dans une cuisine, enfin le plus susceptible d'héberger des bactéries fécales
Bah ce sont les mains du cuisinier.
Donc avant de cuisiner, on se lave bien les mimines
On lave ce que l'on va manger cru à l'eau claire et pour le reste, la cuisson fera son job en tuant les bactéries.
Petit conseil important concernant les planches à découper
Les viandes et les poissons peuvent porteurs de germes intestinaux
C'est pas grave parce qu'ils vont être détruit par la cuisson
Mais ils peuvent contaminer les légumes ou les autres aliments que vous allez manger crus.
Donc pensez à utiliser deux planches différentes.
Oui mais la grande question c'est : est-ce qu'on peut manger ce qui est tombé par terre ?
Et bien la réponse est ...
*Roulement de tambour*
Oui et non.
Vous connaissez peut-être la règle des cinq secondes, qui dit que l'on peut manger quelque chose
Qui est tombé par terre si on le ramasse en moins de cinq secondes
Parce que ça a pas eu le temps d'être contaminé par des microbes en si peu de temps.
Bah en effet, il faut un temps de contact suffisant pour arracher un nombre de germes significatifs
A la surface où il se trouve.
Mais, ça dépend surtout du type d'aliment
Et de la surface sur laquelle ça tombe.
Quatre secondes ! J'ai eu chaud.
Si l'aliment est mou il épouse la forme du sol sur lequel il tombe
Et ça augment la surface de contact.
Et si en plus il est poreux, humide, collant,  il a d'autant plus de chance d'arracher des bactéries.
Mais le plus important ça reste le sol lui même et surtout deux choses.
Le type de bactéries qui s'y trouvent et leur quantité.
On l'a vu, les plus méchantes sont celles contenues dans les excréments humains et animaux
Et a priori y'a assez peu de chance d'en trouver en quantité significative sur votre moquette.
Donc si vous faites tomber votre cookie ou votre pomme chez vous
Ramassez et régalez vous.
Par contre si vous faites tomber votre glace dans la rue ou dans n'importe quel autre lieu public
Vous prenez plus de risque.
Dans le doute on peut-être s'abstenir.
Sachez que si y'a des germes pathogènes virulentes qu'on a pas du tout intérêt à se coller dans la bouche
On s'immunise aussi quand on en avale certains.
Une étude Néerlandaise a par exemple démontré qu'un baisé d'une dizaine de seconde,
Avec la langue hein, on parle d'un "French kiss", un bisous français,
Et bien c'est 80 millions de bactéries échangées et c'est très bon pour le système immunitaire.
Donc continuez.
Merci Docteur.
- On voit pour le rappel hein, vous oubliez pas.
- Ca marche.
Pour finir, retenez deux choses :
D'abord que la partie de votre corps avec laquelle vous êtes le plus susceptible de transmettre des infections
Bah c'est vos mains.
Alors lavez les régulièrement. Surtout quand vous sortez des toilettes.
On est d'accord ?
- Okay
Ensuite que les enfants, les personnes âgées et ceux qui souffrent de maladies qui affaiblissent
Le système immunitaire sont plus vulnérables donc il faut prendre plus de précautions.
Pareil pour les femmes enceintes, leur système immunitaire est un peu chamboulé pendant la grossesse
Pour éviter qu'elles rejettent leurs bébés comme un vulgaire corps étranger.
Mais aussi parce que des infections habituellement pas bien méchantes
Peuvent être vraiment dangereuses pour le bébé et la maman.
Voilà, donc être sale évidement c'est mauvais pour la santé
Mais vouloir être trop propre c'est pas bon non plus.
Continuez quand même à vous laver.
DTC c'est fini pour aujourd'hui on se retrouve la semaine prochaine pour une nouvelle vidéo.
D'ici là portez vous bien, posez moi les questions que vous voulez dans les commentaires
Et abonnez vous pour ne rien rater.
A bientôt !